Microsoft is making its biggest acquisition ever:...
...a 26.2 billion purchase of LinkedIn.
You probably know about LinkedIn.
It's the social networking site for professionals...
...where you can keep track of your business contacts.
You can also look for a job on the site...
...or a manager or supervisor can post a job, and find someone to fill it on the site.
Why would Microsoft want LinkedIn?
There are some potential synergies.
Microsoft Office 365 with Word, Outlook...
...and other programs is the dominant Office suite...
...so you could imagine LinkedIn messaging and content integrated throughout.
LinkedIn is not only growing its user base which is about 430 million right now.
It also has a growing sales, learning and advertising business.
Analysts are forecasting fiscal year revenue of 3.7 billion.
That's an increase of about 25 percent year-over-year.
Microsoft could convince Office customers to let LinkedIn learning courses...
...teach its employees new skills and let its employment services...
...handle job openings.